let's welcome our newest bachelor Ben
Higgins I'm ready to find somebody spend
life with I'm ready to find my wife
on Mondays premiere of The Bachelor the
26 year old software salesman met the
ladies vying for the chance to become
his wife
including the good wood beautiful I've
been the weird my name is Tara I'm 27
and I'm a chicken enthusiast
this is Sheila this is my one true love
the cringe-worthy save the date Jackie
Dion mm-hmm and Ben Higgins hashtag to
Higgins and to home and just the plain
outrageous so this is really this is a
good picture that's it okay no I picked
it out of my garden for you two former
contestants returned Becca and amber
from Chris soules this season but it was
23-year old news anchor Olivia who made
the best first impression you stood out
to me tonight Olivia yes will you accept
this rose this looks like we're in for
yet another wild ride this season full
of ups downs this [ __ ] is crazy she hit
me in the face and of course love I'm
ready to be with one person for the rest
of my life